the first way to legally destroy your
competition by the way I'll explain
there's 13 is Network effects so you can
have different types of network effects
the first type is a customer base so
that's having a large very established
user base that by the nature of it being
large attracts even more people to the
network so if it's just you that's not a
network if it's you and two other people
all of a sudden people are like I want
to join that group but when you have
that fourth really good person now a
fifth wants to come in and as every
additional person gets added that
Network becomes more valuable and so if
you're like how does this actually work
in the real world I'll give you two very
different examples so one is you can
think of Facebook right social platforms
so a platform isn't valuable until lots
of people are on it but once lots of
people are on it well no one wants to
join the small platform because there's
no one's on it but if everyone's on this
one then they can instantly connect with
more people now in a very different
version of that in the hardware world is
telecommunications companies you look at
Verizon you look at AT&T as they were
racing to create their monopolies which
they more or less have and I'll explain
what that word means in a second
they were offering all these benefits
for people joining in in families and
free texting between people who are on
the same network as them so that they
could encourage more people to be on
those networks and then there were
advantages of being inside of it now a
customer base is the first type of
network effect a different type of
network effect is a product ecosystem so
think of something like apple right they
have all these unique plugs and all
these unique softwares and operating
systems that only work on Apple products
and once you buy one Apple product or
two Apple products all of a sudden you
don't want to mix and match PC and
Android and all this stuff into your
world of technology and so they create a
closed loop system where everything
works with itself and if your product is
good enough that you can get people
iPhones then you can get millions and
millions of users to then just buy all
these other core products that they have
less Affinity less Affinity towards and
then force them to use all of your
products because of One champion product
that everyone has and so sometimes if
you're thinking about this for your own
business it's like okay one is there a
way that I can structure what I have so
if more people enter my network from a
customer base it adds value to every
other business every other customer so
the opposite of this is a traditional
service business usually if you're
one-onone with a client you provide
value as soon as you're one on two then
it provides less value and so most
businesses are structured to deterior
rate as more customers come in versus
things like a buyer group so if you have
20 dentists who get together and say hey
we're going to all buy together because
we're going to get cheaper prices then
as more dentists come into that
Association you get more and more buying
power and then you become a greater and
greater Monopoly and have more leverage
over your potential vendors right and so
you can think about incorporating these
elements into your business to make the
business more competitive and harder for
anybody else to disrupt you and this
competitive Advantage is so valuable
that tech companies these massive
behemoths are willing to lose billions
of dollars to establish this network
because they know that once they've
mapped an ecosystem then they can profit
in all sorts of ways the second way to
destroy your competition is exclusive
control over a resource or technology so
let me give you example of resource so
possessing exclusive rights to essential
resources or materials that are crucial
for production for some Goods right so
like the deers Group which is a big
diamond group historically has
controlled a huge portion of the diamond
market and by doing that they made able
control supply and demand and since they
own most of the mines and the
distribution they can basically set the
prices because supply and demand exists
and so believe it or not there's more
diamonds there are dishwashers in the
United States but they're valued more
because they control Supply to keep the
prices high and this is a huge advantage
to them imagine if all those diamonds
got released and they were what they
really are which is not nearly as rare
as sapphires emeralds and rubies are but
how amazing would it be to have this big
stockpile of stuff that you got for
almost nothing that you can sell for
exorbitant amounts of money that's a
competitive Advantage so you've got the
natural world where you've got like
diamonds or there's resources right but
in the technological World you've got
data and proprietary Tech so that would
be patents or a huge amount of data that
other people don't have access to and
cannot replicate legally which creates a
huge bear to entry so I'll give you an
example that's really easy to understand
so Google search will literally never be
beaten at the keyboard inserted search I
want to be clear because there's other
things that can happen later right but
search itself Google will always have
more data because they started first and
so if somebody starts today and can
collect lots and lots of search data
Google still has 20 years of experience
and data on all of these users across
the world and they can use all those
algorithm refinements that they have
that no one else has to continually make
better models which is why even though
open Ai and chat GPT have become a huge
source of search in the world Google's
still very much a threat even though
they're quote behind on AI in that race
they're still ahead on the data and if
SL when Google makes its bigger play
into AI they already have everywhere
you've ever searched on Google Maps
every email you've ever sent they have
the stuff that you buy on the Android
store and everything you search on your
phone they have all of that data and so
they're going to be able to personalize
their AI better because I will make one
bet which is it's the best AI that will
win not necessarily the first one
because as soon as you use a better one
you'll immediately switch so I don't
think that they're in some crazy rush I
think what they want is better and in
fact Google dominated search for so long
that it became so apparent that they
were something that the government calls
a monopoly and so the government has
tried for many years to try and break
apart Google's Monopoly for search and
Google is very good at defending itself
with all the lawyers in the world and
they've pretty much been able to just
keep that Monopoly in place and so these
competitive traits that I'm talking
about for businesses you don't need to
have all 13 that I'm going to talk about
I want you to go through it and be like
is there one of these that I can more
directly weave in to the fabric of my
business so that I develop a stronger
and stronger competitive position over
time rather than an eroding one so
speaking of the government the third way
to crush your competition is government
regulations and Licensing so there's two
types that matter most right now one is
government grants the other is licensing
requirements so government grants have
usually exclusive rights from the
government to operate in some sort of
particular market so that's like
utilities or public transportation and
so things like Amtrak so Amtrak operates
as a government granted Monopoly in the
United States for rail service so they
have exclusive rights to operate certain
routes that literally no one's else is
allowed to operate so talk about being
able to like set your own prices now
there's things that come with that but
talk about like going out of business
it's like well literally no one else is
allowed to do business and as long as
people want the transport method they're
going to stay in business so this second
is strict licensing requirements so
basically you can operate so Amtrak has
this type of service between states or
you could do one service in a specific
area or territory and so like utilities
like Con Edison which is in New York has
a strict mandate from the government to
operate that area and so they have so
anybody who wants to get in there has
super high barriers to entry and just to
give you context how viable this is
Conan Edison's Revenue last year was
about 16 billion so that's more than a
billion a month and since we're in the
great city of Los Vegas I think one of
the big obvious ones is once you go
through the regulatory process of
getting a casino license it's basically
a license to print money because they
say that people can literally just hand
you money with a low chance of winning
the same thing for lotteries because
they're so lucrative because you
guarantee the odds that you win and the
only thing you have to do is Market the
lottery and when people have a chance to
win for money for no work guess what
people do it and so the government has
to grant that and they have big taxes on
those corporations because they know
that they're going to make money and so
I'll tell you a fun hormos family story
uh but one of my relatives in Iran owned
the national lottery and so he did very
well until obviously the revolution
overthrew it and then everything was
confiscated for his family and many
others like mine um but he owned the
lottery and so he was allowed to come up
with all sorts of promotions as long as
he wrote a check to the government and
so these things have occurred across
different countries across borders and
so sometimes Simply Having the knowledge
of navigating the government regulations
to get a grant or permission to do
business in a certain way gives you a
competitive Advantage even something on
a smaller scale as simple in some of the
hard States as getting a liquor license
right if you have a liquor license
you're able to sell liquor at huge
margins right and so it becomes a huge
profit Center in the business and so
that's a small example but they all
fundamentally are around the same effect
now you might be like well how am I
going to use the government stuff well
some massive companies like Oracle
they've been able to get that and I'll
talk about their just way of destroying
competition a second but the fourth way
you can destroy one that anyone can use
is economies of scale and so there's two
different ways that you can attack this
one is cost advantages and so basically
you achieve a lower cost basis per unit
sold through larger scale production and
so that allows you to undercut prices
and deter smaller competitors so it
means other people who are smaller can't
buy the volum that you can and so as a
result can't price as low as you can and
so this is a price based strategy as in
you can still make a profit at a lower
price than all of your competition and
so this is a low cost leader strategy
which typically is paired with economies
of scale where you don't want to get
into and this I want to make this a
clear cautionary tale is that if you're
getting into one of these markets
there's no Advantage this is Dan Kennedy
quote there's no advantage to be being
the second cheapest player in the
marketplace the cool thing with
this strategy is that it gets better
with time and so that's what you'll
notice as a common theme which each of
these points is that as you have a a
greater Network or as you have a more
robust ecosystem of products or you have
larger economies of scale most
businesses like I said degrade with
scale they get worse and harder with
scale whereas if you have one of these
strategic advantages woven into the
fabric of your business as you get
bigger and the business becomes more
complex you have another Force that's
driving your competitors away so you
have something that's very strong and
working in your favor as you scale which
is one of the key traits of becoming a
very large business is having one of
these thoughts into your DNA wov day one
so for example my software company Allen
we started scheduling appointments 100
appointments a day a th000 appointments
a day we got up to four or 5,000
appointments a day and we still continue
to do that in that company and so as we
acquire more data and we send more
messages we get economies of scale on
literally messaging itself and so if
somebody else wants to come in and we're
sending millions of messages a day
they're going to have to pay more per
message than we do and so with that we
know that we actually have increasing
margins as we have more messages that go
out in addition to the data that we have
that no one else has and so that is a
compounding advantage that makes it
harder to compete if someone starts two
years later than us and again any one of
these competitive modes will be enough
to build you a massive multi-billion
dollar company and so you don't need
more than one of these you just need to
do one right all the way the fifth way
to destroy competition is vertical
integration now this is one of the
sweethearts of private Equity because
it's something that usually Capital can
come in to do and this is something that
we've done in multi of our portfolio
companies which I'll talk about in a
second so there's two kind of common
ones that people have one is control
over Supply and the other is
distribution networks so control over
Supply means that you own everything
that is required from kind of click to
close and so in the deers example I gave
earlier they own the mines all the way
to owning the front store right or Tesla
right when Elon is building the cars he
wants to get as close to the supply
chain of like where do I get steel from
all the way to the actual retailers
which are just Tesla retailers that sell
online to the customer so he vertically
integrated the entire chain end to end
and he was able to capture margin at
every step and by doing that you can
have a more profitable business and or
sell products that are better than other
people at lower prices because you can
eat into your own margin and then put
everyone else out of business and so
there are multiple advantages to
controlling your supply one is that you
can control quality all the way through
and everyone is aligned with the end
user and the ultimate business at large
the other piece is that you control
disruption because if you have vendors
that you rely on for key components of
your products if those just those
vendors go out of business then it
threatens your business and so by
controlling all of these things like
controls kind of the opposite of risk in
a lot of businesses if you control those
elements then they are things that you
can manipulate and adjust more
proactively than being reliant on third
parties so you not only capture the
profit and have higher quality you also
decrease the risk of the business so let
me give you a 1.0 example of how this
would work so by being a self-publisher
which I am instead of hiring a publisher
to publish my books I take over a second
portion of the business and so rather
than relying on public Publishers to
print and distribute the stuff that I
have I print and distribute the books
that I sell because I have the
relationship with the customer you guys
and I'm the one who wrote the book I
didn't ghost write it out and I now can
make sure that the the size of the book
which is a little bit unique which I did
on purpose because I want it to be like
a kids book and very approachable those
are all things that somebody else might
not be willing to do now if I wanted to
keep eating up the supply chain I would
then go to buying the warehouses that do
it rather than just simply using the
warehouses that do the distribution and
if I want to take another one I would
buy the printing presses and if I would
to take another chunk up the ladder it
would be I would buy paper mills right
and so you can keep vertically
integrating until it's I own forests
that I take to my paper mills to make
paper and then they go to my warehouses
where I distribute the books that go to
my retail which is me fundamentally as
the storefront that actually get the
customers to purchase and so that would
be a completely vertically
integrated product line and if you think
about there if you think about your
products in that way then you think wow
think about all the margin that's
included in a book right so it goes from
literally water and sunlight which is
what it takes to to grow trees and time
all the way to a quote influencer who
has lots of Impressions and free media
that can drive sales so you're you're
basically selling free media with
sunshine and water and that's where you
have and everything in between is where
all the middlemen take a slice and if
you can eat all of that up you have all
the control the sixth way to destroy
your competition and my personal
favorite is a strong brand identity and
customer loyalty and the reason I like
this one so much is that some of the
other ones I mentioned sometimes they
require a huge amount of time or a lot
of complexity like government
regulations um and some of them are just
require a ton of capital right which if
you're starting a business or you have a
small business it might be harder to
develop over time but this one is one
that you can make with skill which is
why I love it so much which with Brand
Power you can build powerful
associations and then your brand becomes
synonymous with the product itself so
for example Google is synonymous with
search engines Kleenex for tissues
Band-Aids for I don't even know what the
actual name for Band-Aids is because
it's so synonymous like tissue based I
who even knows right and so the
advantage when you have a strong brand
like Nike is that you can simply take
your logo put it on a commoditized
product and get higher conversion rates
lower cost you car customers at premium
prices and so you get massive
improvements to the business because
fundamentally if you can price above
your competition
and increase the demand for what you
have what a competitive advantage and
the thing is is that you can simply
build it with time and skill which is
why I love it and anyone can build a
brand if they know how to keep their
promises and make associations clearly
and deliberately over a long period of
time with what their customers value and
then strongly disassociate with the
things and the people that their
customers don't value until over time
people just estab associate that value
intrinsically with the brand itself and
so me personally I've tried very hard to
teach lots of business stuff to business
owners because I believe that private
Enterprise is the only way that we can
save the world and so I want as many
entrepreneurs getting as big a business
as they possibly can to help the most
customers and do it the right way so
they can build businesses that last so
that capitalism has a [__] chance if
you're a business owner and want to
figure out which of these strategies is
right for your business come out to a
workshop we just started Ed running
these at our headquarters here in Vegas
at acquisition. comom and so if that's
you you can go to acquisition. comom
click scale and if you qualify maybe
we'll see you here way to destroy your
competitors number seven is strategic
pricing and so you can think about this
from a price discrimination perspective
and from a predatory pricing perspective
and I'm using the literal terms don't
read into it so predatory pricing is
basically temporarily low prices where
your profits can Outlast selling at a
loss so that no one else can enter the
marketplace and the most classic example
of this was Microsoft is any person who
wanted to add a new feature to the
micros to compete with Microsoft Suite
they would immediately copy that put it
into their bundle not raise the price
and then that person fundamentally
everybody who already had Microsoft just
kept paying Microsoft and got that
feature for free this is very very
common in software where everyone's in a
features War where they try and copy
everyone else's stuff and give it away
for the same price or free so for
example a simple version of that is
Instagram copied Snapchat stories made
it Instagram stories and basically
stalled uh Snapchat's growth as soon as
they were able to do that right and so
that's a version of it which is
predatory pricing the other is price
discrimination which is founded on
selling different prices to different
people so this is maximizing profit so
someone walks in the door and you say
hey how much money you got and they say
a lot you say okay well these pairs of
shoes are $200 and somebody else walks
in the door and they say you say how
much money you got they're like less
than that guy and you're like all right
well these shoes are $100 you sell the
same product at two different prices to
different people based on their spending
power and so one of the classic examples
of this is Airlines so they collect tons
and tons of data on other users and so
by the way if you have credit card
points with an airline they know all
you're spending by the way and by the
way most Airlines make the majority of
their money on the credit card systems
and just use all of the airline stuff as
the coolest benefits program to get
people to use their cards if you didn't
know that um fun fact they get 3% of all
of what you spend on your credit card
that's their income and so if you barely
ever use your you know Southwest points
but you spend $20,000 a year on your
credit card they make $600 a year on you
no matter what and so if you and
somebody else are looking at the same
flight with the same seat you might get
displayed two very different prices
based on what they know your spending
power is and your need is and if you
have that kind of competitive data
compared to your competition then you
can make more profit than they can and
so regressing this down to a small
business the way I think about this is
being very clear on the one or two
customer segments or avatars that you
really serve and being able to segment
those people so that you can sell to the
right wallet right now so discriminatory
pricing is literally selling the same
thing at two different prices for
different people I don't personally like
this and so the way that I feel
ethically okay about it is I like to
tweak my offer just a little bit so that
when I have the rich person I can add
one thing like a free cocktail with
their thing and charge a lot more for it
but I can still ethically say these two
things were different so if they ever do
meet on the plane and say how much did
you pay for your ticket how much did you
pay for your ticket I can at least if
they came to the owner be like hey why
did I pay 200 this guy paid 160 and we
bought in the same hour be like well you
got a cocktail now the person might be
like well if I had known I'd be like
well they still were different right and
so that at least gives me a little bit
of you know stress fee sleep I'll put it
that way and so having a couple tiny
things that you can change about your
offer this especially works well with
Services allows you to price more
aggressively to someone's spending power
or need while ethically being able to
sleep at night without saying that you
sold the same thing for two different
prices and as a fun bonus for this one
is that pricing compared to all of the
other things that I've talked about so
far is one of the easiest levers to
build and manipulate compared to
government regulation or massive
economies of scale like you can do this
one much faster and you can do it on a
smaller scale so number eight is
exclusive contracts with three different
parties so you can either have exclusive
contracts that control Supply so no one
else can get Supply so if I am Hershey's
and I have a contract with the farmers
group in Africa that gets the cocoa nibs
that are required for chocolate then I
make it very difficult for anybody else
to get into the chocolate business
unless they resell from me which means
I'm still going to make a profit on
their business the second way you can
think about that is customers so
government contracts is a classic
example where if you get a contract like
Lockheed Martin does for making fighter
jets or whatever they make for the
government for defense then the
government is known to be able to to uh
keep that contract and they're only
going to have one for a specific need at
a time and so once you lock that
contract in no one else can really
compete for that core service for years
and then imagine 5 years later well
you've already done this for 5 years is
someone going to spin up a company that
didn't make all that money in that
meantime doesn't have all the
relationships and then get the next
contract probably not that's why
companies like Oracle locky Martin are
gazillion dollar companies because they
basically just siphon off taxpayer
dollars and have locked those contracts
in the third is contracts over
distribution and so you've got the
supply side you've got the customer side
and then you've got reaching the
customers which is basically the middle
between the two and so if I have an
exclusive contract to sell video games
and the only retail distribution is game
stunk right then I can unless there's
other marketplaces for distribution I
can have a huge Monopoly over everybody
who walks into those stores and so
having exclusive contracts with
distribution are ways of locking down
markets well I mean I'll tell you an
obvious one one of the classic examples
of having massive distribution as a
monopoly is Coca-Cola and Pepsi and so
they're the primary two players in the
drink game and the reason is as soon as
they can buy a company that gets some
sort of market share because they
actually have a good product they can
immediately drop it into their
distribution base of every single
restaurant every single 7-Eleven every
single Walmart every single Walgreens
every single retail store they already
have the existing relationship they
already have the distribution and so by
having that locked in they don't even
have to really innovate just wait for
the market to say oh this is a winner
they overpay the founder so that they
get Fu money but they pay that guy 500
million bucks and they immediately take
that thing and make it worth 5 billion
and if somewhere to try and compete with
Coca-Cola they'd have to have a hundred
years of sales and outbound teams
establishing all of these connections
and the thing is is that especially
because Coca-Cola is in the physical
world like there's not a huge like you
have to get the product to physical
human beings so having a physical
distribution Network gives them a huge
competitive advantage and this is just
through contracts they have these
relationships they have these agreements
and they're just already in place and to
the flip side the people who are sign on
the other end of these distribution
agreements if you don't carry Coca-Cola
and Pepsi people be like what kind of
Mickey Mouse thing you got going on here
because they own the vast majority of
the beverages that most people consume
and so when you're thinking about
building your business having these
agreements where you can get access to
distribution increases the value of the
company and secures Revenue because you
get to rely on all the marketing each of
these individual retailers do to get
customers in to buy your product and
fundamentally this is a B2B or B2B Toc
strategy and if you don't what that
means it's business to business or
business to business to Consumer and so
if you want to lock in one of these
things and you're a smaller business you
have to make it worth it for the
distributor and so if they're picking
between you and someone else then you
can say hey I will help you I will sell
you my product at a lower cost than
other people or I'll add in a whole
retail kit that'll move more product for
you or I'll come out to your site and
train your staff for free you have to
add other perks and incentives that more
established players probably aren't
willing to do or don't need to do so
that you can get a foot in to the door
so number nine huge Capital requirements
meaning it takes a ton of money to just
get into the business and so that
automatically knocks out 99.9% of
business owners who aren't going to be
able to raise a billion dollars on their
first go now Elon for example was able
to do this with SpaceX because he's Elon
and by the way casually shot up hundreds
of satellites into space so that he
could create star
right and have Global coverage for
internet and there's other obvious
examples of this you got Exxon Mobile
who has a huge Capital to go find search
and then drill oil or like underwater
oil drilling like these crazy things
that cost gazillions of dollars that
you're not like hey you know I'm
thinking about opening a dry cleaning
store or an underwater oil rig right
like it's it's it's a huge amount of
capital or even simply as simple to
understand as developing a new drug like
a pharmaceutical it takes takes a ton of
time a ton of money a ton of Regulation
so there's multiple big things and a ton
of money because you have to run the
whole thing for years at a loss not
being able to make a penny and then the
day that it gets legalized then you
print money for like 30 years but it
takes time and money and Regulation and
knowledge of regulation in order to even
get to that point and many failed drugs
that don't work which a lot of people
don't talk about and so if you don't
have a huge stockpile of cash you either
got to raise it or you got to not play
which means once you do win it's harder
for people to enter because even if you
do figure out the you know hair loss
fixing drug you're going to have a huge
years and years of profits and advantage
over somebody else who's going to what
be the second player in that market
years later right and I I'll say like
and let's scale this down to small
business so it's easier to start a
social media agency because it just
requires skill than starting a
manufacturing PL or starting a business
where you have to buy Capital Equipment
so a equipment in order to make the
business work and so basically the
amount of capital that's required in
order to start the business becomes a
competitive advantage in of itself and
so if you have the ability to raise
capital or even saving lots of money for
yourself you can automatically pick
vehicles to start a business in that
have fewer people competing against you
so you automatically shrink the pool
number 10 is IP intellectual property
now this is one that I think is wildly
understood but you've got kind of two
basic camps here so you got padon
copyright trademarks which is basically
like I own this information and no one
else can use it so simple example of
that is this book like someone else
can't copy the contents of this book and
then republish it and just put their
name on it it's illegal and it's good
that it's illegal because then people
wouldn't spend the time to write a book
if they knew that the moment it does
well some a hundred other people can
publish the same book right and same
thing with like a cartoon character like
Mickey Mouse which by the way is
expiring kind of soon so that's kind of
frightening for Disney uh but they you
can own these patents for 70 or 100
years or whatever it is and so you
basically have an entire lifetime and
sometimes two lifetimes they're able to
create wealth with this one thing that
obviously lots of people like if it's
good and after that point it becomes
common it means everybody can use it and
so we might some find some very
interesting Mickey Mouse apparel and
cartoons that start appearing after
Disney's Big ownership over that IP
expires now the other version of this is
Trade Secrets and this one's really
tough because it's really hard to
enforce it's really hard to keep secret
cuz you have employees who learn Trade
Secrets and then they can leave and then
just becomes competitive practice and so
the thing is is like the classic one is
Coca-Cola secret recipe for their drinks
and this is actually really common in
flavoring because there's really unique
recipes for like Red Bull and Monster
and I think monster famously didn't own
its own recipe from the person that was
actually doing the manufacturing and had
to pay like $500 million to just buy the
rights to its own recipe from the people
who made it in the beginning some crazy
amount of money somebody can fact check
me all right and so the thing is is that
but if you're like man someone's using
my offer someone's using my ad someone
copied my content that's not considered
intellectual property believe it or not
and so there's very strict guidelines
which I won't get into about it but if
you do have a copyright right if you do
have a trademark which is like you can't
use acquisition. comom right you can't
pretend it's your business and the key
word I think for knowing whether it's
right or wrong is pretending like it's
yours right like you can't pretend that
you wrote this book you can't pretend
that you in acquisition. comom you can't
pretend to represent something that
you're not which is what this protects
and so this gives you the business owner
the opportunity to spend more resources
more time building things of value
because you know they're going to be
protected and if I ever wanted to sell
the rights to my book I would be able to
sell it for probably close to $100
million based on the revenue that this
book brings in and it just continues to
make money and these types of businesses
set themselves up for things called
royalties
and so Oreo for example and Nabisco set
up lots of different royalties with like
supplement sellers who want to say this
is Oreo flavored or ice cream dealers
you you want to have Oreo real Oreo
flavoring so if you want to use the Oreo
recipe and the Oreo logo on your
products they say sure you can use it
you just have to give us 8% of Revenue
of whatever you do and so there's also a
really strong strategy of saying hey I'm
going to just lean into this I'm going
to go get 10 different big Brands to
license me their brands I'm going to pay
them the royalty but I'm going to
piggyback on 20 years of branding and
marketing that they spent gazillions of
dollars on so you can start small
businesses uh a mutual acquaintance of
mine started his suppling company just
taking all these premium Brands like
Swedish Fish and Sour Patch Kids and
making them into supplement lines that
people immediately recognize so he got
the benefit from that brand recognition
and already a flavor that people loved
and knew even though he was a small
business number 11 is Acquisitions and
mergers and you're like how do you
destroy your competition through
acquisition mergers well you kind of
don't you kind of just assimilate your
competition and so this one is a a
darling of the private Equity world and
basically the world that I live in as an
investor which is hey we've got three
companies that are all competing for the
same Market well what if we just buy
them all and put them under one well now
we control the entire Marketplace and so
the government seeks to break these
things up once they get really really
big but the problem is it gets really
hard when it company's really big
because they know how to defend
themselves and so Facebook for example
meta has acquired number of companies
like Instagram and WhatsApp to
consolidate position they added
messenger in and so they have all these
things and they've been prevented at
this point from buying any more because
they don't want one company owning all
of the digital media and I think
rightfully so but that is a way that you
can develop a monopoly and so when
you're thinking about Acquisitions and
mergers you're really just thinking
about market segments or like I was
saying earlier so this one basically
umbrella is on top of any of the others
so you can do private Equity so you can
do Acquisitions for example and acquire
all of the things in the supply chain so
you basically use outside Capital to
acquire the entire supply chain and
vertically integrate or you acquire all
of your competitors and you achieve
economies of scale or you acquire the
distribution and the exclusive contracts
and then you create a closed loop and so
you basically use capital and taking
existing resources and assets and so I
had a company yesterday was talking to
me about this and they were like hey I'm
having this problem because this company
was doing about $60 million a year it's
a roofing business he was like I buy all
my leads from this online lead source
and they're the biggest lead Source in
the US and I'm their biggest buyer I was
like okay cool so what's the problem
he's like well I'm having trouble
scaling Beyond them I was like okay well
there's two ways you can do it you can
either buy it or you build it and my
recommendation to him was hey go find
five small agencies that sell to roofers
exclusively and sell payer lead and
rather than buy the leads buy the
company because he had the capital to do
it and so if he buys one two or three of
the businesses he can then own another
chunk of the supply chain so he owns all
of the media assets that create the
leads and he owns the roofing company
that can create the roofs and then what
would the next thing he would buy he'd
probably buy the financing company that
finances the roofs and he'd make points
on that and so the more you eat up of
this which you can do through
Acquisitions and mergers the more of a
competitive Advantage you have the more
valuable the company and so what's
interesting is that small businesses get
small and stay small through competition
but big businesses think about
consolidation and so you you could see
five business owners who are all neck
and neck in a local market but the funny
thing is is that one guy sells private
equity and then private Equity buys the
other five and just owns them all and it
just seems like the silly squabble and
so if you can work together to create a
much bigger Enterprise the sum of the
whole is greater than the individual
parts and this is very true when it
comes to equity value in a business and
so if you seek to create a more valuable
Enterprise don't think from the
competitive lens think like how do I eat
up things that would cause risk to my
business and so that's looking at
distribution looking at customer bases
looking at looking at media assets
looking at all the different components
so you can say hey is there a way that
we can work together rather than compete
so that we can just become a much bigger
thing and then own a stronger position
in the market which then gives us some
of these Downstream things we have
economies of scale we have a stronger
brand all of these competitive modes
that you then position yourself to
destroy competition and so me personally
and this is something that's be way too
long to learn about business is I'd
rather own 20% of a billion dollar
company than 100% of a million dollar
company and one of the classic examples
you probably have heard of because
you've probably seen their big green
trash bins is Waste Management which you
may not know this but the owner of the
founder of Waste Management didn't even
like start a business he just bought
Waste Management routes and he kept
buying them over and over and over again
and so what he saw was a very fragmented
Market of mom and popop shops that he
saw wait if I added all of these routes
together I would have huge economies of
scale and then I would own the entire
network of waste which is more or less
what he did and and so he grew the
entire company through Acquisitions
until he became a multi-billionaire and
had a big public company which we now
know as waste management and so and so
if you're a small business owner you can
just think about that exact strategy
that Waste Management did which is if
you are let's say a pool cleaner or you
own lawn care company then you can look
at all the other lawn carees in your
local Marketplace and say okay well what
if I owned all of these and you just
focus on your local city and if you own
them you're going to have huge
advantages it's going be harder for
people to come in and compete against
you you have the relationships you have
economies of scale you have more
efficient routes because you have your
houses are closer together and this
happens with lots of Home maintenance
type of businesses and the thing is is
that right now this is a huge private
Equity interest so there's tons of m&a
activity that's happening here because
they're seeing the same thing that's
right there which is wow these guys are
all really fragmented instead of
competing if we consolidate it we make a
much more valuable thing so number 12 is
one of my favorite personally and so one
of my big sayings is find what everyone
wants make it better and give it away
for free and step four monetize another
way so it's having an innovative
business model and so a lot of people
talk about this in disrupting
marketplaces so you take stuff that
other people are currently selling at a
profit and you just give it away for
free and so Google for example with
Google Docs Google Sheets Google slides
to try and disrupt Microsoft or eat up
some of its market share they offered
essentially the same software for free
and added some features that made it
even easier for people to work together
if they were already on Google so
fundamentally many of these models exist
on freemium Concepts which is I give
something for free that you continue to
use and I put all of my effort on
ascending people from free to paid and
so it's actually a marketing strategy
and so your cost to acquire a customer
is the cost to deliver a customer
divided by your conversion rate so if it
cost me a penny to service a free
customer and I convert one out of a 100
free customers into paid customers then
my cost to a Car customer is a dollar
and so you would actually take all of
what would normally be a marketing
budget and you put it into delivering
the free thing and make sure that that
free thing is so good that the word of
mouth marketing on its own because it's
free then generates more demand that you
then just take the cost basis of
delivering the free thing and that
becomes your marketing spend and this is
really common in disruptive businesses
because that is their competitive
advantage that's what makes them
difficult to compete with because other
people in their Marketplace that's their
Core Business and then you're just
giving it away for free because you
found out another way to monetize so
Spotify for example did a great job with
this where they made free music for
everybody because they licensed they
made all these agreements and so you can
listen to whatever songs you want on
demand as long as you're willing to
Jesus as long as you're willing to
listen to ads and if you don't want to
listen to the ads you can pay them Tada
and they do a REV share with musicians
we can get into whether it's ethical how
much they pay them or not but that's not
the point of this video the point is
that they had an Innovative model that
disrupted that industry but you're like
okay these are some massive things but
is there something that I can do on a
smaller scale well the answer is yes you
just have to do the math and so for
example I had a concept that I that we
tested out at a gym it didn't work but I
can still explain it to you is that I
had a meals company called Prestige
meals and I also had a sub company
Prestige labs and I knew gyms and so in
one of our test kitchens I said Hey what
if we told people that if they were on
our meals they could get the gym
membership for free and so we marketed
free gym
forever because the whole shtick was if
you eat the right Foods when you're not
here the results you're going to get in
here are going to be massively Amplified
now the difficulty that we had and I
think if I worked at it a little bit
longer I then was like this is a little
bit of distraction because I was getting
way too into like trying to innovate
this business model but fundamentally
that's how it worked it's just okay well
I have a capital cost for the gym but
once I incur that the additional users
isn't that much to take on in terms of
price and I'm willing to give this thing
away for free that other people charge
for as long as they buy this other
Revenue stream that has more profit or
more income and so that's how I think
about pairing different Services
together where you just take the a very
cheap service that a lot of people want
even if you go from $20 to zero it's
still free and free gets 10 times the
interest of not free and so that then
allows you to generate the demand for
your much more valuable service that you
can sell at a higher LTV I'll give you
another version of this if I that I
would test out so if I had a large
facility right I might say you have to
you can come to my facility and you can
use it for free you have to do these
rules and I can kick you out so that
would control some of the Riff Raff for
example but by doing that I would use my
gym as my free lead magnet to get people
in the door and then what would I do
when they're in the door well they got
to sit down with us to do an onboarding
consultation which we would sell
personal training at and so it's like I
can give the whole gym membership away
for free if you just buy Personal
Training knowing that only one out of
five people are going to buy it and
that's fine because I didn't pay for the
customers and I'm making all my profit
here so as long as my profit and my
personal training covers the cost of
maintaining the facility and I can still
at a profit then I have a good and very
innovative business model number 13 is
control over distribution channels now
you might be like this is really similar
to contracts with distribution and it is
kind of except it's way more valuable
because
contracts at some point they can break
them like all of the vendors overnight
could say you know what Coca-Cola we
don't want you now is that likely no but
if you have absolute control and
ownership over distribution you also can
profit from everyone else's business too
and so Amazon for example owns a
distribution Monopoly right they have
access to everybody in the United States
they're the most widely adopted product
which is Amazon Prime in the United
States in total and that's how they can
get you things in two hours right which
is crazy and they had the warehouse
Network built out first and they were
putting so much strain on the US Postal
Service and ups that they were like well
we're just going to start Amazon's
delivery and now Amazon's deliveries you
see the Amazon trucks everywhere where
they just have their own people that and
their own vans that do all the
deliveries for them and so Amazon
because they have access to everyone's
front doorstep if you want to sell a
product on Amazon you pay Amazon 2/3 or
half of the revenue which is absurd but
it's also why Amazon's revenue is like a
gajillion dollars a year how do you
chunk this down so you're not Amazon
you're like how do I make this work for
me so I would say on a smaller scale you
have local distribution so you can
create distribution centers in a local
area and you just slowly expand outwards
because in that City in that tiny area
you're the best now the other version of
this is that you get really good
Distribution on a specific Market
segment so if I have every single CEO in
America and I know them all first name
basis then if I want to sell private
jets I probably will have a good job
doing it and so just think about it as
means of communicating or means of
delivering messages or products to
customers that you have complete control
over now I don't own those CEOs but
somebody might own those relationships
right and so the idea is as much of that
as that you can have complete control
creates a competitive mode now I want to
zoom out we talked about 13 different
things
here the chunked up version of this is
the actual word monopoly and it comes
from the Greek mono meaning one and pce
meaning to sell meaning only one person
can sell and so there are 13 ways that I
just outlined where only one competitor
can sell and that could be because they
control the supply they control the
demand they control the media that talks
to those people they control the
technology that prevents other people
from getting into it it just costs a ton
of money to get into the business they
have some sort of Grant or license that
says that only they can do it so there's
all these different ways but
fundamentally it's finding a way that no
one else can enter and as much as
monopolies are quote frowned upon in the
government they don't do very much to
break them
up and this is how Bill Gates and John D
Rockefeller created life-changing wealth
but you can create life-changing wealth
and not necessarily become a billionaire
you just create a small network of a
very small niche that you own and by
doing that you can take steps and weave
one of these 13 strategies into the DNA
of your company to make it more
competitive and ultimately make more
money and I told you number six my
favorite was brand and how to build a
brand and I actually made an entire
keynote that doesn't require any money
and only skill to understand and deploy
in your business so go check it out